Shaq welcome to the studio my first
question how much time did you spend
considering taking with the knight in
this position okay I mean he played very
fast until this moment after Queen F1 of
course uh I understand this uh
it's maybe his draw maybe he's a better
way I need to play I mean a night of one
why if kunif one I see after Knight F5
it's better to play without Pawn than
the extra Queen
it's better to play
if you open it no everything yeah if you
open it now everything is better to just
to change and play end game without pong
I mean I I was upset to show Knight F1
is also I mean it's okay but I it was
not well not not today I mean maybe next
day maybe not today today I just think
it's Queen F1 and take 95. because after
Queen E7 it was a new move for me and
yeah after this moment I started to play
myself and I was too much time and
really I think I trade variable and and
the very important moment when I played
[Music]
this move yeah you first take here you
can play is continue yeah I think every
yeah
Knight F1 yeah here is he plays C5 after
C5 I was a little bit in a shock because
I really 93 take Queen F7 I I don't know
after queen of Queen F7 is looks very
easy losing and after nighting fun I
want to play a C5 I want to play Queen
H5 yeah because first 10 or 15 minutes I
calculate this move because I was very
happy with this move take take D4
and uh
sorry Bishop B4 yeah King E2 yeah I
calculate I was very happy because it's
looking for looking for Knight E3 maybe
I mean but yeah I bet after I I find
Bishop C3 move inside of Rook F4 I think
inside of which and after this move I
think this looks like very bad and maybe
the losing position for what and I just
take 93 yeah and after Knight E3 I
calculate okay maybe I can play of the
queen of seven yeah Bishop F5 is very
strange move Bishop F5 that was actually
originally yeah Bishop B5 Bishop B5 Rook
B4
I think okay is minimum I can play this
position but this looks very bad Bishop
before and it's I think it's a very bad
position yeah but I am very happy to uh
I can calculate and find the queen G1
movie definitely can count like when did
you find it yeah okay I think he played
very fast it means I played good
you open Play very fast it means you
play very good his main lines is uh for
this reason I I was sure I some moves
but I don't know which one and uh when
okay he played Queen F7 again very fast
and I think it's okay I need to find
this move or queen G1 it's finally this
move after Queen G1 I start to think
okay white is better but again I is
Queen a fun idea I miss but okay
after Queen G1 okay Bishop C3 is amazing
yeah
yeah of course I I calculate of course
because uh uh but what to do if no truck
F1 is just take D4 I have no move and uh
it's Queenie fun and everything is draw
I mean it was very good from preparation
is from Fabiano and the very good
defense from Mommy dear
we have to agree this was a brilliant
played game considering he didn't know
the engine evaluations Chuck I have to
ask you what were your thoughts
yesterday as your opponent's clock
started ticking down
okay uh of course it is a little bit sad
uh Magnus not continue to play
tournament this little bit set for for
beatful Saint Louis beautiful Saint
Louis chess club everything because
every year everyone happy to play here
and we all hope it Magnus will play of
course all tournaments but
is not easy moment
say something about Magnus
uh
but you know why he's not go uh I don't
know
why he's not canteen tournament he has
not made on the official declaration no
yeah okay if you know you can ask me I
will answer something if not I don't
know
of all right guys you want to join in on
the conversation uh no just I I love the
uh I love the line great preparation
that great defense by uh
is doing our job for us I just feel like
kind of observed because yeah that was a
perfect summary we don't have anything
to add here I guess uh good luck uh
enjoy your free day Shaq uh we'll see
you the day thereafter nicely put really
nice yeah perfect perfect statement of
fact there by